welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Jing Hsu a professor of modern
Chinese literature and culture author of
failure nationalism and literature the
making of modern Chinese identity 1895
to 1937 professor su is also co-editor
of global Chinese literature critical
essays with David der Wong of Harvard
and also co-editor of science and
technology in Republic in China with
Benjamin Elmen of Princeton today we
talk with professor su about her recent
book sound and script in Chinese
diaspora welcome professor su thank you
it's great to be here let's begin with
an overview of your book tell us about
it the book is about native speakers and
mother tongues and globo Chinese
language trade and when we think about
native speakers and other tongues they
seem to go perfectly together
but in fact what this study tries to
show is how much actually goes into
making that relationship there are
writers who are writing those languages
they are colonial policies and national
policies that try to change those
relationships and there's technology of
writing that try to in some ways
circumvent those relationships okay and
what led you to write the book what gave
you the idea um the book as you know I
work on modern China 19th century to the
present and to me this book is very much
it was a timelessness the timeliness
that prompt me to write it and at the
time that when everyone has everyone had
in the world has their eyes on China
there's a sense that even this diasporic
communities which have not been a strong
point of emphasis in this history are
also gravitating back to China and
they've shared a rather contentious
history and one of the remarkable things
is actually the issue of language how
their writers outside of China who might
not even receive Chinese language
education who come to write in Chinese
and they write novels they might write
poetry about
there are places of sojourn in Southeast
Asia in South America in Africa and it
becomes quite interesting to understand
how are they relating to the idea of
standard Mandarin and their writings and
how do you think they are give us some
examples well there's the malaysian
chinese writer who was actually who were
actually quite a man active group at the
moment and many of them were educated in
taiwan for college and prior to that
there are from various places in
malaysia and one of the reason they went
to taiwan and in the 70s and 80s as a
sort of a secondary diasporas because of
course china that time was quite close
to the outside world and that was also
part of the cohort configuration or
taiwan seemed to be a more hospitable
place for their studies and these
writers come to learn chinese literature
basically in a sense that is not their
first context they generally found son
in china so they actually speak at home
they grew up with certain dialects
they're actually not part of they're not
really represented i mean i don't want
the key things is that you know dialects
in general you know we talked about
mandarin chinese and that's basically
all we know but there's seven top
elected groups and there are two
particularly large ones and they're
southern so it's very complicated as to
who decided what was going to be the
standard Mandarin in early 20th century
and but because of the naturalization
process that question was never quite I
think reopened for inquiry and debate so
now these writers haven't been in
diaspora for many decades some of them
born in Southeast Asia or in the United
States North America they come to
question what exactly is their place and
it's a nature relationship not just a
China but to the very language that he
choose to write in and the language that
identifies them as Chinese and why do
you think that matters well it matters
in the sense that language matters to
you or me I mean there's it's it's
interesting how you know being a native
speaker of something we don't really
question we're all born into a certain
kind of language and what's remarkable
that would come to really defend them
with a passion and that to me is what
interesting about Chinese language I'm
sure in other contexts as well because
Chinese language the written language in
particular has this very long history I
mean it's not just something that we use
to communicate in
but it has its origin in a theory of
writing that has to do with the cosmos
it has to do with resonating with a
certain kind of universal pattern in the
universe you know in some ways if anyone
if you've seen Chinese characters you
know that the so called video graphic
which is actually false you understand
that it's easy to project it onto
certain phenomena in the world to say
that it actually resonates with cycles
of nature patterns are produced by waves
or bird tracks or just like figuration
of the clouds so traditionally Chinese
has had this kind of philosophical very
strong philosophical resonance and that
become a source of intense cultural
pride to a degree that especially now I
mean with the I think with the popular
popularity of learning Chinese I mean
yeah we get students who come in and
stress man then they already have six or
seven years of mandarin under their belt
and it's quite remarkable so how that
happens so one of the things that
interests me is precisely how these
writers whether they're they have a
privileged background that is Chinese
speaking whether they're in places like
Malaysia where Chinese was actually
minority language how they struggle to
precisely keep that kind of culture
heritage
well now solely or wholly identifying
with mainland China and how did you go
about your research well the research
the edging I've been working on Chinese
diaspora so the research itself sort of
takes me to different places I do a lot
of archival work in China Singapore
Malaysia Taiwan Hong Kong and as I
continued to ask for a project it's
almost like I'm following the itinerant
their itinerary by going to places like
South America and Africa and Hawaii and
so on and so forth ok and you talk about
Lin's typewriter in your book talk about
why that's so important that is actually
my favorite it was that it was the most
fun chapter to write in the book and I
think it's almost also the most
accessible in a sense that I mean the
book itself I should deals with Malaysia
Taiwan Hong Kong bilingual writers in
North America so these dynamics are
generally between standard languages and
dialects but I think what the Lee Natanz
typewriter chapter does is to translate
that
to an extended show how he has an
extended valence and a kind of global
language war that was happening during a
Cold War period between English Russian
but actually most importantly having
Chinese which had a strong reverberation
so one of the reason that lis neat on is
also an interesting character for lyric
scholar like myself is because he's
actually the most celebrated bilingual
Anglophone writer they were successful
in the 30s and 40s he was very good
friends with Pearl Buck but actually
then falling out precisely over the type
writing project who talks now in a
moment okay and Leaney Tong had been a
very clever bilingual writer he wrote
this essays and and he said he was a
very famous essayist and he had very
clever and very had a great style of
English as well and he got his PhD in
Leipzig and falala G and he so he has
this very long obsession interest and
the brown to 20s 1920s he started to
think about what is the future of
Chinese and at that time he was not
alone there were lots of people were
thinking about what is the future of the
Chinese writing system even before them
in a 19th century the first group of
people who thought about revamping the
Chinese script were actually advocating
doing away with it altogether so as she
came quite close before the nationalist
period right on the cusp of that term
from Empire to nation where we almost
lost Chinese written language and what
would have taken its place well it
depends on whose proposal you will go
with and there were roughly about thirty
plus that that we know of I suspect him
any more than that there are proposals
to go the romanization route so simply
use alphabetic letters there were
proposals to your use shorthand like
Pitman or Lindsley very much following
there's nothing inspired by certain
congressional hears in the states that
were actually taking shorthand so these
Chinese observers at the time felt quite
they were quite impressed by this and
they want to import that because the
crux of the issue is this longer
contention is the the struggle between
the eto graphic and alphabetic language
and there's this long prejudice thing in
the eto graphic is more it's like a
picture it's more it's not really
amenable to abstract
King that is not even amenable to
science laris not amenable to scientific
advancement because people are tied down
with hours of learning I mean thinking
back to you the way I grew up I did in
fact spend hours every day practicing
characters it's just and there are is my
correct 3000 of them or so uh you need
about four to five thousand for average
literacy oh my goodness there are a lot
more and I think the most difficult
character has something about somewhere
about 30-something strokes so that's a
lot of lines a lot of certain my order
of the strokes to remember and
timeliness I mean it takes a while I
would imagine
do you write anything and this is this
is a well-known of long-standing
complaint among not just a Chinese but
missionaries who went to China whoever
has to figure out how to translate or
romanize the Bible for Chinese
consumption so they were the first ones
who came up with seven these different
schemes but that's different from the
19th century script reformers who want
to come up with your own thing so some
also also opted for certain kinds of
alphanumerical system that's a perfectly
patterned on the book of change so on
and so forth quite a so tarik what's
funny is that all of them thought these
proposal would be really easy to learn
that if you've used their scheme you
will learn I think one of them says
eight weeks a day in two weeks you'd be
completely fluent in China oh boy and I
can tell you from personally working
through these different themes they're
not at all intuitive yeah and also
because sounds change right I mean in
fact writing is very stable and there's
Chinese writing systems are very stable
over the centuries but you know the way
we talk really it's quite different even
from you know if you look at old movies
some 40s and 50s I mean they already
speak behind American English it's very
different from the way we sound now well
going back to your the comment you just
made it it's very standardized I would
imagine that you have individual people
making these Chinese characters I would
imagine it would vary from person to
person how they would make that
character and that would cause some
problems down the line versus the
typewriter which is standard every time
you're making the same mark that is
correct and that's that's one of the
that's one of the outcomes of the
yawns typewriter I'm a type writing
technology is about the age of
mechanization standardization so on and
so forth but what was key about leaving
town's typewriter was not that he
standardized he helped he want to
standardize it but he wanted to make it
available and easy to use for non
Chinese speakers this is quite
extraordinary okay this his idea was
that for any person who doesn't know
Chinese at all they could come to this
keyboard look at it and immediately know
how to use it and how this accomplished
well he came up with a crucial scheme
which is how you parse characters so
indexing Chinese characters is a very
laborious feat and they've been several
systems for it Bellini Tom thought all
of them required that you already know
the language already in order to look it
up in a dictionary and he wanted lookup
system that would be intuitive to
anybody so he devices to me who's never
seen that's right okay so you if you are
standing next to the Yukons typewriter
you'd be able to use it why because the
way a set up is there are 72 keys on
this keyboard which is the crucial
component and he divides the all Chinese
characters into top and top and bottom
components so 38 keys are about the top
component and the rest are or 30 36 are
the top components and the rest of keys
signifying lower component code and what
you do is you look at a character that
you want to put in the typewriter you
can identify just the top part and the
bottom part you look at the
corresponding parts on the keyboard you
press the two keys down at the same time
and then a little window is supposed to
pop up in front of this machine that
sort of dashed on to it and then I'll
give you a range of five to eight
choices which is just how it works out
mathematically and one of them is gonna
be the right character you're looking
for and then you go to where the current
date space bar is so in lean times
typewriter this space bar is divided
into eight separate keys individual keys
just number one to eight and that
correspond to the different character
Isis in its pop-up window then the third
step is that you press that
corresponding key to get the right
character that then gets slapped on it
seems complicated to me
it does seem complicated now but I tell
you it had remarkable it had remarkable
repercussions because what were they
well this is this is a way of making
Chinese characters readily globally
accessible the characters yes but still
the meaning was there a disconnect
between picking the characters and and
what you actually wanted to convey
well that is still a yes that is
generally that is that remains a problem
actually how we want to that this
there's one there's one problem to
replicate know how to reproduce the
character but it's a separate issue to
sort of make sure that it matches up to
the right meaning but that's not really
a danger with Leaney sound typewriter
okay the idea is that this keyboard
which helps to basically a mass and to
recall characters that will you add
computer technology to that then you
have very powerful ways of translating
from machine like one character into
like a different language which is what
eventually what what what makes this
remarkable is that many Kong's
typewriter coins at a time of Cold War
cryptography were very interesting idea
of machine translation using Chinese and
just so happens about time leaned on was
done with it he has sold the copyright
to Merton taller Linotype company but it
was too expensive for them to develop on
mass so what happened was at the same
time the u.s. the US Air Force was
actually conducting experiment and
trying to tap into the machine
translation and they decided they really
needed that one keyboard that could help
him with a basic conversion problem and
they decided on this keyboard and so
leaning Tom's keyboard ended up in the
hands of IBM to whom the US Air Force
turned the project to to develop further
and in collaboration with several
American universities including Yale
that this keyboard then became sort of
blueprint for a later typewriter they
they unveiled in summer in 1963 were you
able to find any research at Yale in
terms of that part of the story as how
they were actually there was um there
was a scholar from the 40s and 50s who
is actually the first person and
United States who wrote about language
standardization and natural language in
China he unfortunately passed away
couple years ago he was in fact I yelled
for a very very long time and actually
towards the end of his life when I had
the pleasure of visiting him in his home
in Hawaii is John de Francis he actually
shared many of his unpublished works and
primary sources with me the most
remarkable is in this beautiful home
that he has in Hawaii japanese-style
house there was actually a typewriter
that he had been working on for years
and he was his version
his host of the Chinese language
typewriter and did it come to fruition
were able to use it no unfortunately
that the technology was not quite there
and he was basically doing this on his
own and I have to say this is many
people were trying to join this race of
coming up with that one chinese
typewriting technology I mean Leaney
Tong had several competitions at the
time and even before him decades
beforehand Western missionaries have
been trying to do the same but his was
really the one that helped to translate
and make it accessible for global usage
you were gonna tell us a story about his
falling out with Pearl Buck ah well
Leaney Tong was a very successful writer
and many bestsellers in the English
language and he basically pour these
resources into this typewriter we should
have been working on for most of his
life and he really did it with a passion
and what happened was Pearl Buck was the
one who brought him to United States and
convinced him to settle down here and
become a writer he was kind of a
spokesperson for China and English
language how did they ever become
acquainted um they met in China actually
cuz the Pearl Buck also spent some time
China and that's where she met him but
after he came he was so obsessed with
the project he kind of needed extra cash
I think he almost became bankrupt for
his own resource into this and story is
that he bar trying to borrow money from
them and they sort of had a fallout but
I think there were other issues as well
like what kind of writing he was gonna
write for the American audience someone
who so forth right okay so what do you
conclude in your book well after
studying this you know the very
different locations where Chinese
language is written by Chinese or non
Chinese it seems to drive a wedge
between the
a native speaker and the kind of
standardized language that could be
their mother tongue or in a national
language so one things I conclude with
in the book because language has so many
so much to do with also ideas of race
and ethnicity is that you know the idea
of native speaker has been to language
what color has been to race data to Sade
has really been one of those perhaps the
last bastion of constructive
essentialism that we still embrace
without too much reflection and it has
played out throughout the 20th century
played out many different conflicts
ambivalence and I think individual and
collective traumas in a way that one
might be voiceless without a language
for instance you might think of Taiwan
writers during the Japanese colonial
period so their mother tongue though
they were not supposed to even think in
Chinese the idea that they were supposed
to think in order to become Japanese
citizens were having on them quite
citizens but become proper Imperial
subjects they were supposed to think in
Japanese so hard is that well how hard
is that to police so there's all kind of
things that there's kind of the interior
tea to the idea of native speaker as
well you know how we embrace I mean as a
literary scholar you know it's it's a
joy to be read to be able to read and
once mother tongue you just have a
different sense of that language a
different feel but you know that that
kind of unquestioned sense of an innate
access to something I think also colors
how we think about race or gender so any
of these that have been dismantled in
the past few decades this thing has not
really happened for language and of
course like what happens when we
dismantle the idea of a national
language and what is supposed to mean I
mean that actually spells out I think
quite a challenge for literary studies
at large right where we're still
organized very much by national language
departments yes well fascinating stuff
thank you so much for being here with us
thank you for more information about
Professor sue and her work please visit
our website at Yale edu slash macmillan
report be sure to join us again for
another episode of the Macmillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
and area studies at Yale